hello guys
welcome to simply learns live session
today we will discuss the best way to
begin with coding in the year 2021
let's wait for an ample amount of time
so that few more people can tune in
by the time please allow me to tell you
that we have daily updates on multiple
technologies
so if you are the tech geek in a
continuous hunt for latest technological
trends
then consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and hit the bell icon so
that you can never miss an update from
our
end
so we have a few more people now hi
everyone
welcome to simply learn 2020 has been a
year of
many things but one thing that hasn't
stopped is the technology
and to master any technology you need to
have a good understanding of programming
how to solve a problem and
much more and today this particular
video is dedicated for the same
i will be explaining you the best way to
learn coding
and what to do and what not to do
so without further ado let's get started
so the first phase that we will
encounter when we want to learn coding
will be few doubts and questions
they are why exactly do i need to code
well there are many reasons for this
particular aspect but most of the time
you want to get started with coding
as coding is the buzzword and it's the
only way for you to get placed into your
dream company
that offers you a big fat package to
live life
king size once you get into your job it
becomes your responsibility
to give your best and frequently keep
yourself up skilled
to stay ahead in the race and earn
bigger than ever
so that was all revolving around one
point that was
huge salary package there is also
another reason why people always
really get started with coding
there are a few enthusiasts for always
in the hunt for latest technological
trends and
updates on various platforms and
programming languages
ides frameworks and much more this is
what keeps them proactive in learning
how to code
so the bottom line of the story is
regardless of the reason that is driving
you to learn code
it is possible for everyone to do it see
coding is that one magical stream that
anyone and everyone can dive into
and happily build a beautiful carrier of
your dreams
so this was about why you need to code
so the next point
is all about what to code where to code
and how to code
so these kind of questions the decision
that you believe can change your life
so it's all about choosing your field
as for the current it industry there are
multiple possibilities to start your
career with
all the major carrier options boil down
to three
major streams they are mobile
application development
desktop application development big data
and data science so before you begin
with your carrier in any of these three
technologies
i would request you to do some research
about these fields
there are possibilities that you might
have already worked with some
fundamentals of these technologies
for example if you are well versed with
kotlin
and java programming languages some of
the popular ides like
eclipse intellij android studio then you
will definitely find it easy to begin
with
mobile application development also you
might want to learn a little bit of
shift
so that if you want to work with ios
application development
then it would be helpful after that if
you have a good understanding of php
python and some good scripting languages
such as
javascript etc then you can jump into
desktop application development
everyone knows sql and every programmer
has some decent fundamentals
in mathematics so it must be really a
great
option to choose your career in big data
and data science
because the foundations of big data and
data science are laid on sql and
statistics
mainly and this is the easiest and
simplest way to build your career in
coding
so we will discuss each of these career
options
in detail and also the languages
frameworks and ideas
that you might want to get well versed
with to begin with your career in these
fields
so the first one we have is the mobile
application development
one simple reason for the increased
demand of mobile application development
industry
is a rapidly rising number of smartphone
users and business
undoubtedly the world is revolving
around the digital experience and
on-demand applications which have become
an integral part of our daily lives
the growing popularity of mobile
applications and increasing operating
systems
pull out the two major concerns for the
startups
with roughly around 5.5 billion
smartphone users
that used mobile phones globally today
making mobile application
development one of the most booming
market in the world
so the mobile application development
fields
need the following things as the
fundamentals
we have languages frameworks and ids so
when we come into languages
we have kotlin java and swift and
similarly when we get into frameworks
we have flutter shiftic react and
finally we have the ides on the right
side column which are the apache cordova
android studio and visual studio don't
worry
we will discuss each one of these things
from languages frameworks to ides
in detail and depth so the first segment
that we will be discussing to begin with
your coding experience
with mobile application development is
the languages
so first we have kotlin many startup and
fortune 500 companies have already
developed android applications using
kotlin
if you want to start using kotlin for
android development
read google's recommendation for getting
started with kotlin on
android if you are new to android and
want to learn to create
applications with kotlin then using
kotlin for your application development
gives you an edge
so why does kotlin is highly preferred
so this features might help you out to
understand
why kotlin is the best kotlin helps you
to learn coding combined with greater
readability
matured language and environment
followed by that
kotlin's strong support for android
jetpack and other libraries
then interoperability with existing java
programming language
support for multi-platform development
code safety
easy learning and finally the kotlin has
a biggest community of fellow developers
who are enthusiastically waiting
to help out fellow developers next we
have
the schwift swift has changed the cost
of ios
app development industry it has highly
intuitive programming language
for apple operating systems like ios mac
os
and watch os the language has opened
new doors to entrepreneurs to make their
idea
work which was impossible for a long
time
earlier ios application development used
to be
time consuming difficult and the
frequency of
app crash was really higher before swift
ios application development was mostly
done with objective c
a subset of c programming language with
added object-oriented features
but app development using objective-c
was really tough
so swift offers you some of the
best-in-class features that include the
following
easy to code and maintain data
management
high interactivity linux development
support
better code safety and finally
performance at
lightning speeds next we have java
programming language
java is an open source object-oriented
programming language
that makes it one of the most popular
choices among others
also high frame as one of the best
programming languages
java opens up the door to innovation
when it comes to coding with each
passing day
the java programming language has been
becoming
more approachable some of the major
reasons to choose java for the mobile
application development
are java is an object oriented
programming language
followed by that java is an open source
programming language available for all
the developers
next java has a seamless community of
fellow developers to help you out
to resolve your real-time issues next we
have a very important point which says
java is always easy to learn and finally
we have the last point which says
java embraces powerful development tools
so moving ahead we will discuss the
frameworks to be used
for mobile application development so
the popular frameworks for getting
started with mobile application
development
are flutter shift and react
first we will discuss about flutter
flutter can make launching mobile
applications
more comfortable for startups to roll
out their feature-rich mobile
application
without getting a burnt hole in their
pockets
that means cost friendly next flutter's
hot reload feature makes it standard
apart from the crowd
this feature allows developers to
quickly and easily
experiment build ui add features
and debug their apps in real time no
matter how complex your project is
developers can easily turn your app idea
into a perfect solution
by simply leveraging the broad choice of
built-in beautiful materialistic design
including rich motion apis widgets
smooth natural scrolling behavior and
many more
as it is open source therefore
developers can explore
countless design options while
developing an app with flutter
next we have shrifttech swiftic is the
worst
leading do-it-yourself app creation
platform
our unique platform enables anyone
quickly and easily create custom mobile
applications
and sites for all major mobile devices
like iphone
and android with minimal cost and no
coding necessary
swiftic provides easy to use user
friendly navigation
and provides a wide range of integration
options
shiftic also has a large window for
design flexibility and
template choice next we have react
native react lets you create
uncompromised native mobile applications
with ease along with high fluidic
performance
react offers the following features fast
and cost effective
application development next we have
application development with
better user interface and user
experience
code reusability easy transition of
web applications to mobile applications
and finally
highly compatible with third-party
plugins
now moving ahead let us quickly discuss
the ides that you can choose
for mobile application developments
the simplest and the beginner level ites
for
mobile application development are
apache cordova
android studio and visual studio apache
cordova
enables developers to build
cross-platform mobile applications with
html5 css3 and
javascript the developers can use html5
and css3
to render content and javascript to
render
logic also they can build amazing hybrid
mobile applications using
several javascript libraries next we
have android studio
android studio has always been the
one-stop solution
for android application development if
you are a beginner
you may feel that android studio is
really difficult tool
but trust me once you know how to use it
properly
your life as an android developer will
become
so easy android studio is a great tool
to build
android applications and lastly we have
the microsoft
visual studio microsoft visual studio
provides
an android emulator for android
application development
you can build applications for android
ios
and windows devices by using visual
studio
as you design your application use tools
in visual studio to easily add connected
services such as
microsoft 365 azure app service
and application insights build your apps
by using csharp
and net framework html and javascript or
c plus plus now with this we have
finished
with what it takes to begin your coding
with mobile application development
now let us continue with desktop
application
development so desktop application
basically deals with the web-based
applications that run on standalone
desktops or
laptops desktop applications are more
popular than you can imagine
if you use microsoft applications or
browsers like
google chrome and firefox you would
definitely understand
what role desktop applications play in
our work lives
and business if you are planning for
desktop application development
then that can be a great choice so for a
beginner there are some
easiest and simple programming languages
frameworks and ids that are as follows
so for programming languages we have
python
shift java now on the next column we
have the frameworks that
are beginner friendly such as
microsoft.net
electron java swing and finally on the
last column we have the ids that are
preferable by the beginners
such as pycharm spider and microsoft
visual studio now first we will learn
about some programming languages
at first we have python python is an
interpreted high level and
general purpose programming language
unlike other programming languages
python does not require the developers
to express their concepts
by writing longer lines of code the high
level programming language has designed
with emphasis on
code readability at the same time as an
open source programming language python
makes it easier for enterprises to
reduce the project os significantly
python is highly flexible
that is why software developers across
the world use python
for developing desktop applications web
applications
and much more some developers even
prefer
writing mobile applications using python
using additional tools and frameworks
followed by python we have schwift
schwift is an apple's open source
general purpose programming language
that developers used to develop
programs for ios mac os
watch os tv os linux
and set os platforms the apple bag swift
project has now released downloadable
swift tool chain images for windows
so this can contain everything needed to
build and run shift code
on windows operating systems followed by
swift we have
java all desktop applications can be
easily developed using java
java also provides graphical user
interface development capability
through various means mainly abstract
windowing toolkit that is
awt swing and javafx
while awt holds a number of
pre-assembled components like menu list
button swing is a graphical user
interface widget toolkit
so swing provides some advanced elements
like
trees scroll panes tables tabbed
panels and lists so followed by the
programming languages
let us learn about the frameworks so for
desktop application development
the following are the best ones to begin
with we have dotnet
electron and java swing so dotnet
consists of number of tools
libraries and compiler components these
tools along with dotnet specific
programming languages can be used for
desktop application
development that runs on windows
next we have electron electron is a
dream come true for web developers
it is a revolution that makes things
easier for them
we all know that the interface is one of
the crucial elements in
software and these days there are
several options to create different
kinds of interfaces
but it had always scattered the web
applications
and installed programs desktop apps were
relegated to
background but not anymore they have
risen from ashes
and are making a strong comeback thanks
to the frameworks like
electron followed by electron we have
java swing java swing is a part of
java foundation classes that is jfc that
is used to create
window based applications it is built on
top of
awt that is abstract windowing toolkit
api
and entirely written using java
programming language
unlike awt java swing provides
platform independent and lightweight
components
the java x dot swing package provides
classes for
java swing api such as j button
j text field j text area j radio button
j check box j menu j color chooser
and many more with that we will now
discuss the ides that you can learn
to use when it comes to developing
desktop applications
so the first ide is the pycharm the
pycharm ide
is one of the most popular editors used
by professional python developers and
programmers
the vast number of pycharm features does
not
make this ide difficult to use just the
opposite
many of the features help by charm a
great python ide for beginners
next we have spider spider is basically
an
acronym for scientific python
development environment
it's intended for use as a workbench for
scientific computing with python
and that's reflected in the feature set
the packing
and the overall behavior of this
particular ide
spyder has useful features for general
python development
but unless you work mainly with ipython
and scientific computing packages
you're probably better off with a
different ide
so followed by spider we have the visual
studio
for the developers who work with
microsoft development services
visual studio is the best using
microsoft visual studio
you can develop high quality
applications for windows
microsoft office windows phone the
internet
and the cloud most developers say the
software is the best solution for
microsoft application development
now we shall enter the next segment that
will be about big data and data science
the big data era and its golden flight
run have already taken off
like other similar technologies there
will be many roller coaster moments
but it's going to be a fun ride you can
upskill and get to learn
a lot from this particular segment so
you can begin with the following
languages
frameworks and ids
so the languages are python r and
javascript
and when we get into frameworks we have
django
tensorflow apache spark and finally for
ids we have
pycharm spider and atom so first we will
deal with languages
so according to recent studies python is
referred as the best programming
language for data scientists
data scientists often need a easy to use
programming language
that has decent library availability and
great community participation
so having good fundamental knowledge on
python
can prove to be helpful next we have
our programming language r is a language
designed especially for statistical
analysis and
data reconfiguration this makes our a
perfect choice for data analysis
and projection members of our community
are very active and supportive and they
have
great knowledge of statistics as well
next we have javascript unless you have
decided that you want
to learn data science first then you may
learn
python r r first otherwise i recommend
javascript over other programming
languages for beginners
and startups the javascript's learning
curve is not steep
so for this reason we use javascript for
both
client-side and server-side programming
nodejs is efficient because of its
single threat even callback mechanism
this enables us to develop
scalable real-time applications it's all
about picking the right tool for the
right tests
although python has developed a robust
ecosystem
of data science tools and helps data
scientists perform analytical work
i believe in the future javascript will
help
development of ecosystem for data
science tools and
its own flavor in the near future now
let's check out some top frameworks that
you can begin with
so first we have django django is
basically a web framework
so for data scientists who want or need
to work with the development of web
applications
django will be a good choice as most of
them already know
python next we have tensorflow
tensorflow is a framework created by
google for creating deep learning models
deep learning is a category of machine
learning models that use
multi-layer neural networks machine
learning has enabled us to build complex
applications with great accuracy
whether it has to do with images videos
text or even
audio machine learning can solve
problems from a wide range
tensorflow can be used to achieve all of
these applications
so followed by tensorflow we have apache
spark
it is easy to see why apache spark is so
popular
it does in memory distributed and
iterative computation
which is particularly useful when
working with machine learning algorithms
other tools might require writing
immediate results to disk
and reading them back into memory which
can make
use iterative algorithms and which
happens to be
painfully slow but that's not the only
reason to like
spark now let us learn about the ides
that you can choose to begin with your
career
in data science
so first we have pycharm pycharm is a
dedicated ide for python
python to python is what eclipse to java
the fully featured integrated
development enterprise is available in
both
free and paid versions dub community and
professional editions respectively
it is one of the quickest ides to
install with a
simplistic setup thereafter and
preferred by data scientists
for those with a likeliness for ipython
or anaconda distribution
know that pycharm easily integrates
tools with matplotlib
and numpy this means you can work easily
with array viewers and
interactive plots while working on data
science projects
other than that the ide extends support
for javascript
angular javascript etc this makes it
opportune
for web development too followed by that
we have spider
spider is open source and it is
specially dedicated
ide for python what's unique about this
ide is that
it's optimized specially for data
science workflows
it comes bundled with anaconda package
manager which is the standard
distribution
of python programming language spyder
has
all the necessary ide features including
code completion
and integrated documentation browser so
followed by spider we have atom
atom is free open source text and source
code editor available
for a number of programming languages
including java
php and python the text editor supports
plugins written in node.js
although atom is available for a number
of programming languages
it shows an exceptional love for python
with its interesting data science
features
also apart from python spyder and
pycharm we have another ide
which is jupiter notebook born out of
ipython in 2014
jupiter notebook is a web application
based on the server client structure
it allows you to create as well as
manipulate notebook documents
called notebooks for python data
scientists
jupiter notebook is a must-have and it
offers one of the best
intuitive and interactive data science
environments
so this was all about choosing your
right field and the programming
languages frameworks and ides required
for your field
now moving ahead we shall deal with the
next part of our tutorial
that will be about
the best resources to begin with
so once after you select your right
career path you need to start searching
for the best resources to begin with
coding so there are numerous online
resources available
to get started with coding you can refer
to top ranking
articles and you can also refer to
youtube tutorials
and you can also wisely invest your time
studying and going through some offline
books as well if you have some
so if you ask me i would recommend you
the simply learn
youtube channel for online tutorials and
also
simply learn official website where you
can get thousands of
free resource articles so when you start
your youtube application
and navigate yourself to simply learns
youtube channel
then you can find out that simply learn
has numerous tutorial videos
based on a wide range of technologies
and every concept is explained using
beautiful infographics and for a better
understanding of the concept
they have also included practical
examples
not only this on their official website
they have
free resources for all the courses so
just navigate yourself to the resources
and inside the resources on the left
hand side
you have got all the technologies that
you are looking for for example
just click on the big data and analytics
and inside that you have
numerous number of articles along with
the codes you can
execute on your local system you can
learn the concept and execute the
programs in your local system for better
understanding now that you have a brief
understanding of
better resources the next step would be
to try building projects
so once you decide the career path and
get all the basics you need like
programming languages
frameworks and the ids that you can work
with
then refer to some online tutorials and
examples everything
once you feel that yeah i can do
something on my own
then you should better start building
your projects
so projects basically play a very
important role in
learning a new different concept
so once you start building your project
the first
thing that you will encounter will be an
error or an exception or
some other problem so whatever the
technology you're learning or whatever
the career you have chosen
the major aspect of that particular
carrier or the major aspect of that
particular technology
will be the problem solving capability
so even after learning coding when you
join into a company
then the major aspect the company will
look for
is the problem solving capability so
don't
get panic when you get a problem when
you execute a code
so you have multiple sites where you can
get
solutions for your problems so google
will be your first line of defense
so whatever the error you face just copy
that
error and paste it on google search bar
and you will find the solutions for that
similarly stack overflow is another
website
which has a huge community of developers
regardless of whatever the programming
language whatever the framework
whatever the problem you have there are
multiple people
or multiple fellow developers who have
faced the same
error and have fixed it and they have
posted their solution
over there apart from google and stack
overflow
we at simply learn have our own
personalized community
with thousands of developers who are
enthusiastic to help out
beginners with your issues so when you
navigate to
google search window and find out
community.simplylearn.com then you can
find yourself in the home page of
simply learns community where you have
multiple technological streams
and if you find any error or any problem
on your coding part
then you can visit this site and place
your queries here and
we will answer your queries as early as
possible
not only this we also have separate
telegram groups
where you have multiple programmers and
developers from various streams who are
real-time programmers and they have
years
of experience on that particular
technology and they're ready to help you
out on your issues
so for example we have learned python
programming
where we have multiple developers and
real-time programmers
who are ready to help you out when you
face
any problems in your programming we have
also learned data science we also have
learn full stack developers we have
learned java programming
and many many many telegram groups with
many programmers to help you out
whenever you face any issues on your
programming part
i will drop the invitation link to these
groups
and if you're interested then please
feel free to join us and we will be
happy to have you in our group
and we will be really happy to help you
out in your coding part
now we enter into the next step so you
might have a doubt that
why do i need to start with a project
when i have the basics of programming
so to understand this in a simplest way
let's have a simple analogy
so what's the importance of programming
so building your project is really
important as you will personally get
your hands on the project and you will
have a better understanding of
real-time technicalities of various
aspects like ides programming languages
tools use dependencies and many more
so unless you get your hands on your own
project you will not have some good
problem solving skills
so this can be explained better through
the small example
imagine that you wanted to become a
cricket player
so if you wanted to become a cricket
player then what will you do
of course there are some ways so the
basic ways are first you need to
understand what the game is how many
players
you will be having on your team and on
the opening team
what are the roles of the players like
fielder keeper
batsman bowler everything so once you
get the basic knowledge
then what will you do will you practice
play and perfect your play or will you
just continue to watch your tutorials
and learn
the theory part of the cricket so to
become
an actual cricket player you need to
practice
play and perfect your play once you get
the theory done
unless you do it you cannot become a
cricket player
so similarly unless you get your hands
dirty in coding
you cannot become a perfect programmer
so followed by that simple analogy
we have our next part what type of
project you need to choose
so before beginning with a project you
might have your friends who are working
for
a company in a dream role that you
wanted to be in
or your friend might have finished a
project that you are interested in
so you can contact your friends and
consider having a discussion with them
about the project you wanted to choose
what might be the technicalities of the
project so that's kind of an approach
and you can also build your portfolios
for your future purpose of future
reference
so that you can help out your friends
when they are in need of that
so for a beginner there are multiple
approaches are multiple openings for
building your projects
for example you have software
development data science and artificial
intelligence machine learning
game development web development mobile
application development and
many more so to begin with
software development you might want to
become perfect with some programming
languages such as
c plus java python etc
and similarly for game development you
also have some programming languages
like
c sharp c plus plus and others
then you have data science artificial
intelligence and machine learning
for which you might need javascript
matlab r
programming language and python followed
by data science you have mobile
application development
which requires swift programming
language kotlin
pyson and java so
then we have web development for which
we might need
node.js react php html
javascript css and many others
so it all depends on your choice so some
may prefer
python with php some may prefer node.js
some may prefer
html js css etc so it all depends on
your choice
so basically to begin with a project you
need to have a better understanding of a
programming language first
so now let's understand how to begin
with a programming language
so to start with a programming language
you need to have some fundamentals of
that particular programming language
so the fundamentals such as data types
keywords and variables
loop statements conditional statements
exception handling and many more
so at first let's have a briefing about
data types
so having a better understanding of the
data types will help you to choose the
right data types for the job so that
your program will not have to face silly
errors based on just
data types next you have
the keywords and variables so every
programming language has
its own keywords which have special
meanings
so if you have a better understanding of
keywords then you will avoid yourself
from using the keywords for variables
and
creating an ambiguity that you may find
really tough to come out of so it's
better you have the
briefing of keywords first
then you have the looping statements and
conditional statements
so basically looping statements and the
conditional statements happen to be the
spinal cord of
coding in any programming language so
using these conditional statements and
loops
you are going to define the
functionality or the logic of your
program
so it's really important that you go
through this first then followed by that
you have the exception handling so
exceptions are
serious problems in any programming
language so
just for an example consider that you
wanted to perform some operation like
division so you successfully write the
program and you
give it to the user what happens if the
user enters some
wrong input such as some special symbols
or
0 etc then your program will crash right
so you can avoid these problems by using
exception handling techniques
by using try and catch methods which
will tell the user
to provide the right input in case if
the user provides a wrong input such as
zero or
special symbols so this kind of approach
will provide
an output without crashing your program
so exception handling also plays a major
role
in starting to learn a language
so with this we enter into our last
topic which is
buy the best courses
so the perfect solution to learn coding
in 2021 would be to buy the best
classes and leading training courses
online
online courses not only helps you to
train correctly but
also helps you with real-time projects
problem-solving skills
and interview assistance so simply learn
is one of the top
e-learning site that provides you the
best-in-class online courses with
problem-solving skills along with
real-time projects and interview
assistance
to find your dream career so when your
google for
simply learns official website then you
can find yourself landing on this
particular page
and for example if you wanted to take up
data scientist program then you can
search in the search window
for data science then you can find
yourself on this particular page
which has the data scientist masters
program
you can see that this particular masters
program
has been collaborated with ibm and it
has been provided a rating of
4.7 and it's the world's leading
number one online boot camp
so scrolling a little further you can
find out details about the program
and after that you can see the tools
covered in this particular program
and a little bit information about the
program advisor
the learning path
the courses offered in this particular
program
and the electives that you get along
with the program
and finally you will get the simply
learns
masters certificate in data science
i'll drop the link for simply learn's
youtube channel
simply learns community simply learns
telegram groups
and simply learns official website in
case if you wanted to buy their courses
so with this we have come to an end of
this particular live session
if you have any queries regarding this
particular tutorial
you